Sorry,
I am a Foley and I'm be coats,
but we're also Liz and Beth and uh,
yeah,
we're here to talk about what would be to,
could do everyday problem solved by history's most remarkable women.
Um,
so it's been a really amazing year for the sort of application of women's
voices,
um,
particularly in the UK with this centenary year of women's suffrage.
And,
uh,
it's also as part of that,
there has been lots of raising awareness of the achievements of women from
history that have perhaps in the past been kind of let slide a little bit and
we're,
you know,
very much endorse the theory of you can,
if you can see it,
you can be it.
And so our book is designed to kind of,
to help women deal with the problems that might come up today,
even though the women themselves are actually from times far back in the past,
we have chapters on women from different cultures,
from different backgrounds,
covering lots of different disciplines.
So we have sports women,
women involved in science and literature in piracy.
Um,
we know it's a really noisy conversation.
There's conversation about women right now,
but we want to take the stories one step further and see if they could actually
help us in our daily lives.
So the way our books organized is it divided into 50 short chapters and each
chapter focuses one particular high achiever from the past.
And each of them answers a very specific problem and some of those problems are
serious and some of them were being slightly more lighthearted with.
So we have may west on body positivity,
we have Emily Dickinson on defining Fomo,
we have Grace Hopper on facing up to failure and granular.
Molly who's our pirate is on work life balance.
Um,
but we're obviously here in a,
in the middle of a working day.
So we wanted to look at,
I'm certain women who are,
who might help us in certain dilemmas that might come up in the er working
office life.
So we start with someone who is very famous for being very good at her job.
So Elizabeth,
the first is somebody that I channel daily.
And particularly at this exact moment in time cause we were talking about how in
relation to public speaking,
um,
okay.
So dry man.
Yup.
Sweating Palms.
Yep.
Voice all weird weekend.
Hi.
Really trying to counteract that.
What most of us approach public speaking with a rising sense of dread.
It's true.
But if we can learn to sort of fight the fear it,
the rewards are very rich and also it's worth just noting that pretty much all
of us are going to have to do it at some stage during our lives.
Um,
Elizabeth the first was,
uh,
had a very tricky start in life.
She was a toddler when she was banished from caught by her father Henry the
eighth,
who also accused her mother Anne Boleyn of,
uh,
adultery and had her beheaded,
which is kind of excellent dad skills to start you off with.
But nevertheless,
she became queen and 15,
58,
after her sister died and she inherited a country that was completely divided
by,
um,
religious conflict.
So her first job was to reinstate Protestantism,
um,
and she had to use all of her sort of persuasive interpersonal skills.
And does it end a very staged managed of authority to,
to,
uh,
to achieve what she achieved.
So with,
within one year,
she had got rid of the pope as the head of the Church of England installing
herself naturally in that place.
Um,
she,
she'd reestablish the Church of England as well,
and she basically had taken a decision not to force her subjects to
interreligious conformity,
which was what her sister had done.
So Mary before her had done that with a lot of burning and murder involved and
Elizabeth was clearly hoping to end up with a better epithet than bloody Mary's,
what she was called.
And so Elizabeth was wildly clever.
We know this.
She was fluent in French,
Greek,
Italian,
Latin.
She enjoyed translating the classics in her spare time.
She composts on it's as well.
And our third time basically she was a massive overachiever.
But even for someone like her,
it must have been pretty tough to walk into parliament and express herself in a
room full of much more politically savvy men.
Um,
and I think what she was really good at was putting on a sort of imperial show.
And this is another thing that she sort of harnessed in her working life,
which we could,
which we can do.
One of her sort of big hobbies was um,
drama.
So under her there was this great flowering of sort of English literature and
drama of course Shakespeare,
um,
and Spencer,
but also people like Thomas Kids and Christopher Marlowe as well.
And that's actually something that comes up in lots of kind of modern guides to
public speaking,
is that watching actors,
performers,
a really good way of honing presentation skills.
So she was doing that all the way back.
Yeah.
So obviously her private life was a matter of great public interest and she had
many suitors and she obviously she was known as the Virgin Queen.
And at one point parliament got incredibly grow jumpy about the succession of
the throne and they threatened to take away her,
her allowance essentially.
So she made one of her,
she used her sort of rich rhetorical Moxie in that instance.
And she made one of her great speeches and her best cross voice and she said,
at present,
it is not convenient,
nor never shall be without some peril unto you and certain danger.
And to me,
so she was brilliant at holding off parliament and also suitors,
but she was also good at holding off her threats from abroad,
from abroad,
most famously against the Spanish armada.
In 50 88,
she appeared,
there's this brilliant moment where she appeared with the troops at Tilbury,
um,
in full regalia.
Um,
she had this real genius verse of grandstanding and swashbuckling.
Yeah.
And she actually,
she turned up in a long white velvet gown with Arma on a gray horse to make her
red hair look particularly good.
And um,
she,
what she was doing there was very visibly channeling Boudica from the past.
And we talked a bit about Boudica later.
Yeah.
Um,
so she was there,
this was like the ultimate ultimate kind of motivational speaker.
She placed herself with her troops to gee them up.
Um,
and the speech was amazing.
So she uses this great line where she says,
I know I have,
but the body of a weak and feeble woman,
but I have this heart and stomach of a king and a King of England too,
which is a sort of brilliant,
humble brag in some ways.
She's sort of acknowledging what the truth was,
might have been thinking like,
are we being led by a woman?
But at the same time and then the next sentence completely sobriety and saying,
I am your leader.
Um,
she also knew when to deliver a bit sort of emotional sweet talk in a public
way.
Um,
the,
her final farewells farewell to parliament is known as the golden speech and it
basically made them all cry,
which we think is a great send off.
We're not going to do that today.
Um,
but she said,
she said to them though,
you have had many princes more white mighty and wives sitting in this seat yet,
do you have never had any more careful and loving?
So we think maybe the next time we're trying to do a tricky presentation to our
line managers.
We can remember the tough crowd that Elizabeth was facing.
Um,
for her,
her reign was known as the Golden Age.
I mean,
that might be too much to pull off as your tenure in the accounts department,
but hey,
it's a good thing to aim at.
And finally we have some tips from Elizabeth.
So first thing is thinking about presentation.
Obviously wear white velvet,
all opportunities,
um,
alcohol in small doses does no harm.
Um,
and also remember that worst thing,
worst things do happen at sea,
particularly obviously if you're the Spanish armada and most of the time,
99% of people watching a willing you to smash it.
So,
or they're just thinking about their dinner.
So either way,
it's not something we're fine either way.
Um,
so the next person we wanted to talk about as someone who was also very good at
putting on a good show,
and this is 1930 screen siren Hetty Lamar who was known in her day as the most
beautiful woman in the world and she was so beautiful that people found it quite
difficult to believe that there was anything much going on behind her gorgeous
green eyes.
Um,
we talk about her and knowing your worth because we love heady.
she pursued her work passions in the face of much nay saying and resistance and
she was an actress,
both an actress and an inventor and the inventor part of her life has had a lot
more coverage recently and she's been celebrated for that more.
Um,
although still with a lingering sense of surprise that someone who looks so good
could be so clever,
particularly if they're a woman,
because we all know women are rubbish at science as well as fighting,
parking and barbecues.
So Patty was born in 1913 in Austria and she grew up in a cultivated and
comfortable home and she went to drama school in Berlin.
And after that she got her first big break and how it was sort of like a high
brow version of the Kardashian sex tape because she was involved in a Czech film
called ecstasy,
which was the first widely released film to have an explicit sex scene in it,
which it was.
It was banned in the u s it was denounced by the pope.
Her parents went to the premiere and had a very uncomfortable time.
It's very sweet actually by modern standards,
although head he does run around stock,
isn't it?
And there is a famous scene where she's acting out the sexual ecstasy of the
title,
which apparently was achieved by the director poking her bum with a pin in order
to get the desired effect,
which is quite a disturbing way to deal with a teenage colleague.
But it did launch her on her celebrity career path.
She had something really interesting to say about that career path where she
defined it as she said,
the ladder of success in Hollywood is usually a press agent,
actor,
director,
producer,
leading man,
and you're a star if you sleep with each one of them.
In that order,
which is kind of extraordinary that she was saying that 50 years ago and feels
very depressingly familiar to us.
Yes.
Um,
how these new found style light was quite quickly snuffed out by her possessive
husband.
He was a wealthy fascist arms dealer and um,
he was not keen on people watching his wife in this film.
So he rounded up all of the prince to destroy them and heady soon tired of his
controlling ways and she liked it one night,
apparently according to her story,
dressed as a maid,
she snuck out of their castle and ran away to London.
And whatever the truth of that is a good feisty background story to give herself
to make ourselves stand out against the other kind of want to be stylets that
she was up against at that point.
She was really good.
I think like Elizabeth the first at using storytelling and building a narrative
to make you standout.
Exactly.
Um,
by 1938,
she was cast in her first English language film.
And from that point on she found herself mainly cast in so seductive exotic kind
of roles,
which she became a bit bored with to the point where she started her own company
so she could avoid it.
But in 1949,
she went back into the kind of low cut gowns for um,
sessile to meals,
Samson and Delilah,
which was an enormous hit.
Yeah,
it was a films,
the Groucho Marx said,
it said debate,
I'm not interested in a film where the man's tits are bigger than the woman's,
which is a kind of,
again,
a bit depressing thing to say about the women's role on the silver screen in the
golden age of Hollywood.
And Heddy was certainly not just TNA.
She had a singular brain inside her head.
And when World War Two came,
she was very keen to be involved in the war effort and she had well living with
her ex husband should pick it up.
Quite a lot of knowledge about arm.
So essentially whenever the third rate came to dinner,
she was there.
Just having a good old listen to what they were talking about.
And she teamed up with a pianist called George and tile.
And together they developed a frequency hopping radio device to help missiles
get through German defenses,
which they donated to the navy for free,
the patent for free.
But it was not exploited at that time.
But I think as most people know now it has become that technology has become
part of Wifi and gps and things that we use all the time now.
Um,
and had he really loved inventing things.
It was like her proper top hobby.
She applied to the national inventors council,
but they rebuffed her.
But she used to,
when she was on film sets certain tinker away.
She invented new designs for traffic signals,
a fluorescent dog collar,
um,
a tissue box and also,
an idea for a powdered fizzy drinks cube that you could drop into your water to
make yourself coke.
But people were much more interested in her six marriages and her latest
scandalous behavior,
which included lawsuits and extreme plastic surgery.
Um,
and her kind of Accenture cabi didn't really fit with the marketing of her as a
kind of Hollywood sex symbol.
And so it was not until she was 84 that she was recognized as an inventor.
And that's when she and George were given pioneer awards from the Electronic
Frontier Foundation.
And she said brilliantly,
well,
it's about time.
So no one could rock a center parting,
a bold lipstick and an elegant understanding of spread spectrum broadcast like
Heddy thank you.
But the important thing we felt we learned from her story was to follow our own
interests,
even if others
can't see the point.
She was brilliantly clear on where she attributed to her own volume.
So she was very proud of being an inventor.
But she famously said of the glitzy bit of her career,
any girl can be glamorous.
All you have to do is stand still and look stupid.
The next step we have a debt.
So a head is,
uh,
involvement in the war was undoubtedly patriotic,
but it was kind of at a distance.
We have some women in our book who's,
um,
involvement in war was really visceral,
very close up and a depth.
One of the first ones we talk about her in terms of being open to experience and
not being afraid of our mistake.
So it's the,
the parallel we make in the book is,
you know,
that feeling when you press reply,
you think you've pressed reply and you've actually press reply all and you've
sent something about your colleague to the whole floor,
uh,
will debt.
She made a mistake like that and it bit,
it changed her life kind of completely.
And what we wanted to think about is instead of when you send that email,
locking herself in the loo and thinking,
oh my God,
if you could think of a way to keep your chin up and be brave and try and learn
to,
to learn from your mistakes rather than be completely cowed by them.
Yeah.
For her it had life changing amazing repercussions,
which is good news for all of us who make that mistake on a regular basis.
So she was born in 1912.
Her Dad in France and her father had been a decorated,
um,
had been a decorated hero in world war one.
He was killed in War World War One.
And every Sunday her grandfather took her to his grave and said,
if war comes again,
it's your duty to,
to do what your father did.
Um,
which I think today's child psychologists would have a field day with that,
but I don't,
it was made of stone.
She was.
So then she married a British guy and she moved to London.
Um,
and then when the second world war broke out,
she,
I'm her husband and lifted.
And then the battle of Britain and the blitz,
this kind of reduced London to a real proper war zone.
So she moved to Somerset with her mother in law and by now three small children.
So again,
stern stuff to go and live with your mother in law and three small children.
Yes,
absolutely.
Um,
when she was in Somerset,
when she heard a BBC broadcasts asking for holiday photographs from northern
France,
and because the lift Pfeiffer controls,
um,
a French aerospace and the Brits were trying to figure out a way to map their
bombing raids.
So she sent this letter saying that she was,
she knew the area,
like the back of her hand,
but she misaddressed it.
She sent it to the ad,
not to the admiral admiral to which is where it should have gone,
but she sent it to the navy and they then passed it on to the army who then
passed it to the Soa,
the special operations executive.
And they immediately thought this woman would make an amazing spy.
Um,
but what they were worried about is,
you know,
she was a woman.
She had three small children.
How would she cope if she was captured and tortured again?
You know,
they couldn't know that she would prove to be as hard as nails.
And in fact,
that three small children can prepare you to resist torture.
Exactly
by Pumphrey.
Both had three small children.
Um,
so at that did agonize,
but eventually how sort of horror of what was going on in her beloved home
country one out.
So she,
she began and she learned all the good stuff,
Morse Code,
how to handle firearms selfdefence resisting interrogation.
And her final report was glowing,
but it did note a complete unwillingness to admit that she could ever be wrong,
which is a strategy that is worth bearing in mind if you ever are dealing with
the fallout from emailing and error.
Yes.
So Dat was no agent asked 23 and she was dropped into northern France to work
for a man called Peter Churchill,
um,
in a,
in a resistance group very quickly.
They were betrayed by somebody inside the group and she was handed over to the
Germans and they got very confused by this Peter Churchill's situation.
They,
they thought he was a relative of Winston Churchill,
um,
and a debt was very happy to go along with that.
Um,
they've taught you to her horribly.
There are descriptions of what happened to shed and ripped out.
She had,
she was burned on her back with hot irons,
but she stood completely farm and didn't squeal.
So eventually the Germans sent her to Ravensbruck concentration camp.
And the commandant there again had heard the story about Peter Churchill,
who she claimed she claimed they were in a relationship and the fact that he was
Winston's relative.
So he thought we had kind of hostage gold on his hands.
And when the allied forces were closing in,
he took a debt in his car with the plan to hand her over to as a bargaining chip
essentially to the Americans.
Um,
but that turned out to be a bad plan from the common done because a debt
immediately dobbed him in and she stole documents from his car and she then
later testified against him.
I'm so amazingly,
Peter Churchill also survived the war and when they came back to London,
a debt,
uh,
divorced her husband and married Peter.
So she did get her.
Mr Churchill.
In the end,
she was awarded an MB and she was the first person to be awarded the George
Cross for Gallantry.
She died in 1995.
At the ripe old age of 82,
and she's just this brilliant icon of bravery and resistance and all round
hiders nails,
womanhood and all because of a mistake.
So I think the lesson we took from her is that,
you know,
if you're wrong,
if something goes wrong for you,
think about your reaction.
It's also the ability to deal with the situation.
Um,
when there's a massive cockup which kind of makes us potentially better human
beings.
Um,
and actually aiming for constant perfection probably leads to massive
unhappiness.
So we moved from one Morea woman to another,
our title lady,
um,
many centuries before a debt.
Um,
so what happens if the pursuit of your passion like heady and your openness to
opportunity,
like at that leads you into conflict with others.
So women in particular suffer cultural pressure to be agreeable at all times.
And we talk in our book about how lucky we are to have had women like Rosalind
Franklin,
like Cleopatra or Coco Chanel,
difficult women as they were called,
forging an alternative path.
But this pressure does still remain and our next subject is Boudica on sticking
up for yourself.
So she's nor fix best known queen.
She's a woman from history who totally stepped outside of the lane of what was
expected of a lady.
Um,
her reputation sort of rests on her unusual levels of assertiveness or what you
might call blood blood thirsty,
revenge,
revenge fueled aggression.
Anyway,
so Boudica stories full of hold holes and legendary embellishments,
but it's generally agreed that she was the chief of the IC and I tribe in East
Dang Day or about 2000 years ago after the Romans invaded Britain.
Um,
they made an agreement with her husband that he would be able to continue to
govern his own people very generously.
Uh,
but when he died,
that gentleman's agreement did not extend to the ladies and they immediately
took Buddha because land and not content with just that,
they also publicly flogged her and raped her children.
Um,
so this is all according to their historian Tacitus.
and he's the best source that we have for what Buddha could then did.
So instead of being cowed by this or accepting the inevitable sexual violence
that comes to women in situations of conflict,
Boudica set the world on fire.
She led a full on revolt and she burned the cities of cultures,
doesn't Orbens and London to the ground,
uh,
killing almost all the inhabitants,
both Roman and Britain.
And she almost managed to wipe the ninth legion,
I think off the face of the earth as well.
And there's that brilliant fact,
isn't it?
Apparently she literally left her mark.
So if you dig down,
there's a layer of red sediment,
which,
which is from her burning.
Yeah.
So she's the first of,
in a line of,
um,
female rules that we talk about in the book in which include Cleopatra,
Elizabeth the first and Catherine the great.
And they were celebrated as anomalies because it was so unusual for women to be
in positions of power.
And Tacitus,
as I say,
the most reliable source about her was really obsessed with how weird it was
that there was a woman leading an army.
He elsewhere talks about all the shrieking that there was,
because women were allowed on the battlefields in Britain.
And this is like horrified him.
But the Romans were particularly sensitive to this because they didn't think
that women were logical enough to handle a high stress leadership roles.
And they were very sensitized to this by Cleopatra.
Everything that happened with her kind of sex and death thing had really freaked
them out.
Um,
but Tacitus was himself grudgingly impressed with how Boudica dealt with what he
acknowledged was extreme dishonor.
I mean,
so obviously the DFA,
the offenses against Buteyko much more serious than anything we might come up
against in our normal working lives and,
and,
uh,
murder,
mutilation or definitely not the response to any everyday problem.
But we saw something in her emphatic response that we thought was inspiring,
albeit with less disempowering mutilation.
Um,
sometimes extreme disrespect does warrant a noisy counter attack and Buddha can
nurture the very literal no prisoners take no prisoners attitude.
But I think she can act as a source of encouragement for those of us who
struggle with expressing dissent.
She wasn't worried about making enemies.
She wasn't worried about causing a scene.
She was confident in her own authority and that meant that other tribes rallied
around her.
When she,
when she started her rebellion,
we can't claim she had a happy ending.
The Romans turned out to be pretty good at fighting as well as construction,
aqueducts the legal system and deploy heating.
That's right.
Um,
but the Roman emperor did actually rethink his policy for colonizing Britain and
go with them.
A less aggressive kind of starts on it after her a bolt because it was so
significant to them.
Uh,
she died by suicide boot occur to avoid capture and to add insult to injury,
her name has been misspelled for quite a long time as Boadicea and that is
apparently due to a kind of miss.
A typo essentially in one of Tostitos is manuscripts being copied when they were
copied from by one person to another.
And legend has it,
she's buried between two platforms,
nine and 10 at kings cross station.
So she's apparently very near here.
Um,
the ambiguities in her story mean that she's been repurposed as a symbol for
many different causes.
Um,
we don't know whether she was pro or anti empire.
We don't know whether her concerns were primarily political or domestic.
Was she a war hero?
Was she a war criminal?
What would you think about Brexit?
Uh,
her reputation lives on because UK loves an underdog.
Um,
and also because she categorically refused to be swept aside by the more
powerful forces that were in play at her time.
So sometimes it's the nice thing to do to be nice and back down,
but sometimes it's important to fight for what you believe.
Absolutely.
So next up is suffer.
Who's another figure who sort of,
whose reputation,
uh,
sustains despite the sort of best,
best efforts of history to raise it.
Um,
suffer is someone else who went her own way.
And in our book we talk about how in backing yourself,
um,
so when it comes to criticism,
we believe there's no one nastier than ourselves.
Um,
it's very easy to beat yourself up when the meeting doesn't go to plan or a deal
doesn't come off.
But instead of sort of throwing ourselves donor well of self hate,
what if there was another way?
And how do we go about shushing that belittling in,
in,
in a voice?
Uh,
we think Sephora has something to tell us about accepting ourselves,
warts and all.
She was a literary sort of smash in her own time.
Uh,
the ancient Greek poet who's,
who had nine volumes of her work at the very famous library of Alexandria,
and the librarians there named her as the only woman in their night.
Boster of nine prime poets.
And even Plato who was not a big fan of poetry quarter,
the 10th Muse.
And,
but by the Middle Ages,
almost everything of hers had disappeared as partly to do with like the ravages
of time.
So the library,
that library Alexandria suffered a huge fire in which all sort of original
documentation was lost.
Um,
it's partly to do with the fact that she wrote in a very particular dialect,
which by the Middle Ages or didactic,
but blame also has to lie at the feet of some of the clergy,
men of the Middle Ages who were totally freaked by the sort of joyous sexuality
that's right there in her poem.
One of them called her a sex crazed whore who sings with her own wantonness,
which is not what you see on the back of the penguin classics edition.
But,
um,
in the last two decades,
so fragments of her poems have been rediscovered and they revealed whole
sections of suffers,
um,
rhymes.
And it's really interesting that people immediately knew that this was the
Suffolk,
uh,
that the,
that it was Sappho because she had invented the suffix stanza.
Yeah.
And you have to be pretty confident in yourself to feel that you need to invent
a new poetic form to express your genius.
Yeah.
So all aspects of her life had been the subject of sort of feverish speculation
over,
over the years.
W,
you know,
we,
the truth is we don't know very much about her.
We don't know what her sexuality was.
We don't know if her,
who family were,
but we do know is that she's associated with the liberal island of Lesbos.
But because,
um,
attitudes to homosexuality in ancient times are so different to how we might
consider them now,
it's very difficult to see if she was a lesbian or not of it.
He's a Roman poet about 500 years later,
came up with a theory that she ran kind of romantic finishing schools for girls
that she was teaching them the art of love through her,
through her programs.
Um,
but what's amazing is even though we know nothing,
what we do have at these problems and what sort of sings out to test across the
millennia is this incredible voice and her host of feelings about,
about love and romance.
Um,
there's a very famous,
slightly uninspiring Lee titled Poem Called Fragment 31.
And the setup as she's watching on jealously is some man floats with this
beautiful girl and she talks about it.
It's just an incredible articulation of desire in jealousy.
She talks about her sweating palms and her ears are thrumming,
her bloods kind of pulsing in her veins.
And what's amazing is that she's,
she's really in touch with her feelings about love.
There's no fear of that emotional vulnerability.
She owns her weaknesses and her fallibilities
and she does the same.
And another poem where she talks about aging and she talks about how kind of
knackered knees and her sagging skin.
And that's not something that she feels she needs to hide or
exactly.
So we've got some rules about backing yourself.
Um,
first of all,
it's good to remember that nobody's perfect.
In fact,
imperfection as sort of traits shared by all the very best people through
history.
We're bound to come up against other people's judgment just to suffer his work
did.
Um,
but you should try to stand strong on that.
And remember,
it doesn't matter what you look like as long as your soul is in really good
shape.
So Satta Safra had a great line that says a handsome man,
God says,
image a while a good man will one day take on beauty.
So we're pitching our book as it kind of inspiring and hoping that it fills
readers with kind of vim and vigor to take on the issues of the modern world
with these great role models.
But it did also strike us the a book of 50 really high achieving women who
changed the world might actually make us feel a bit inadequate.
And our next heroin is actually someone who makes me feel quite an adequate.
So she is the 18th century interpreter and explorer,
psychic aware and there's no way that I could do what she did,
which is travel thousands of miles through uncharted territory with a new baby
strapped to her back the whole time.
And I really hate camping.
So that is clearly out of my comfort zone.
But we do think there's also a broader message to be taken from her life.
So [inaudible] was born,
um,
she's a native American from the Shoshone tribe and she was born around 1788 and
she lived,
she was the daughter of a chief,
but she was kidnapped when she was very young by an enemy tribe called the
[inaudible].
And they sold her to be essentially the extra wife of a French Canadian trapper
who was the melodiously names to song Charbonneau who had the income odious
reputation of being a rights thinker.
He was described in reports of the time as a man of no particular merit and
apparently and attempted rapist.
But of course we have no records of what second could we have thought of being
married to this guy.
Um,
in 1804,
the US president decided that he wanted a military expedition to explore the and
colonized west of the continent and the leaders of that expedition arrived in
[inaudible] village.
Um,
and they had the grandiose named the core of discovery.
And I was thinking it was funny,
the core of discovery that basically missing the fact that it was not an
undiscovered land for all of the native people who already live there.
Um,
the core was led by Captain Lewis and Lieutenant Clark and they were keen to
find interpreters to help them on their journey,
particularly they were going up the Missouri River into potentially deadly
territory and Charbonneau and a second ago we're between them could speak French
Hidatsa and Shoshone.
And so they were employed by Lewis and Clark even though at that point a sacral
area was heavily pregnant with her first child.
And in fact,
the expedition set off,
um,
just two months after she had had her baby.
So she had a little boy,
John Baptist,
and then she strapped into her back.
She was 17 years old.
She set off on an all male expedition about 60 men and just her carrying him on
a back,
traveling all the way to the Pacific,
mainly by boat.
And it was her survival skills and her geographical knowledge,
which contributed a lot to that expedition.
And there's that famous story,
isn't there,
where she had to jump in and have husband capsized the canoe at one point,
she had to jump in and rescue their supplies down.
So it was a really tough journey.
Uh,
they were kind of a set by illness.
There was the threat of attack from hostile locals.
There were grizzly bears.
One man did actually die.
Um,
but Sacagawea made it all the way to the Pacific and then all the way back
again.
Um,
and this expedition helped the mapping of the west and the eventual expansion of
the United States,
and she was a key player in that.
Um,
so sometimes the constant recalibration of work life balance can feel
impossible.
But I think Zachary where's story puts this into perspective.
Most of us these days don't get kidnapped.
Get to choose who we marry,
get to choose whether or not we want to try and have kids as a starting point.
Um,
and traveling thousands of miles with a two month old on your back certainly
puts the school run into perspective for us.
Um,
it's hard to find a better example of an unstoppable heroin to kind of pep up
your spirits and make you feel like anything is possible.
Absolutely.
Okay,
so our next,
uh,
heroin is in head.
You,
Anna.
And we talk about how and creativity.
So obviously we're here in Google.
We don't need to tell you anything about creativity,
but what if meetings and whatsapp groups in the kind of constant daily use of
millions of emails is crushing it and you can't fight,
you can't find the time for your creativity to juices to flow.
Well,
we know that feeding your inner imagineer leads to huge rewards.
Your jobs are better.
You can ease your relationship,
tensions,
it can make you genuinely feel more alive and fulfilled.
And,
and had you,
ana is an ancient Mesopotamian princess priestess who took it a step further.
She didn't just revel in her creativity.
She owned it and she's our,
she lived around four and a half millennia ago.
So she is the most ancient lady in our book.
So this is a bit difficult to say,
but she was basically the daughter of this King Sargon
of [inaudible] who appointed her a high priestess of the Moon,
God Nana and the goddess Inanna in the holy city of or which is a bit of a
mouthful,
but anyway,
that is in southern Iraq.
So her father,
the king was trying to unite a warring kind of empire states by putting his
daughter at this,
at the head,
at the center of the,
in the earliest role.
She obviously took her responsibilities seriously,
um,
and was good at it because we know she remained in the job for over 40 years.
Um,
and she backed herself the claim in that 40 years of being histories,
first recorded writer.
So the first recorded writer,
either man or woman in the planet's history.
Yeah.
Which I,
I'm still staggered by as a fact.
Uh,
we know a lot about her because of her creative legacy legacy.
There's a body of work that she left behind in the hymns and poems that she
constructed.
And there's also some fabulous stone engraving called the disc of and had you
honor,
which depicts her,
uh,
taking part in a ritual and she has a kind of bald crouching priest at her feet.
She has amazing braids and a turban and she's clearly a woman at the top of our
game.
And that,
yeah,
so the poems and him show us her character and her poems are kind of amazing
because they have a proper narrative arc.
And this is four and a half thousand years ago,
but there's one in particular,
it talks about a political threat.
She suffers then she,
she begs her goddess for the power to,
uh,
to,
to Ricoh revenge by the end of the poem.
She's,
she's back in her,
um,
proper position as the holiest priestess.
So there are loads of amazing things in this poem.
And we particularly like the line mistress of heaven with the great pectoral
jewels,
but most astonishing is I sort of sense of authorship and ownership.
Um,
again,
she's the first recorded person to use the first person.
Um,
and she does it in the designs which says I am and,
and had you honor.
And she says,
I've given birth to this song for you.
And I love that line because it set,
it gives us a feminine kind of slant to this idea of the process of creativity.
Um,
and it's worth remembering.
She was doing all of this about a millennium and a half before homer was
tackling the Iliad and the Odyssey.
And so she has,
I think all the traits that we associate with really creative people.
She was original,
inventive,
passionate,
committed,
fiery,
um,
and all of that is doable.
I suppose the thing to remember is we don't have to all be in the business of
laying down art that will remain for centuries,
um,
to feel that we're being creative.
Um,
I rethink.
It's to do with everyday creativity.
And for me that that means just generally asking more questions about
everything,
but it could also be about trying to be just more spontaneous in your daily
life,
disrupting your,
uh,
your everyday patterns in different ways.
So the next lesson we have,
uh,
it comes from what seems like a slightly unlikely place,
um,
but covers an issue that I think haunts a lot of people for far less significant
reasons than it might have haunted famous concubine.
Nell Gwynne had she been that way inclined.
And what we learned from Nell was how to ride out shame and embarrassment and
stop apologizing for ourselves all the time.
So,
uh,
Elena Gwen's origins and not 100% clear,
but,
uh,
she was thought to have been born in 1650.
She grew up in coven garden.
Her mother ran a brothel,
a as a teenager.
She got a job selling oranges at what's now the theater royal in Drury Lane.
Um,
and those were very exciting times and kind of theatrical circles because,
um,
the theater has been closed down for 11 years by Olivia Cornwell.
And the king had just recently been restored to the throne.
And as part of reopening the theaters,
you also allowed women to act on the stage for the first time because obviously
in Shakespeare's time and around that only men could act on the stage.
And this opened the stage door for Nell who became the best known and most
celebrated comic actress of her day.
And she was reviewed by Samuel peeps as pretty witty Nell.
But,
and then there was a slightly rude amendment,
wasn't there when he called her a bone?
Mary slut.
Yes,
she played,
she starred in plays by the likes of Dryden and she was admired by people like
Aphra ban and the Earl of Rochester.
And she had three boyfriends called Charles.
And the most significant of these was the King Charles.
The second,
um,
who ensured her lasting fame.
Uh,
she met him in 1669 and by the next year she had given birth to his child and
Charles set her up in a house in pal Mel.
And one day she,
he,
he was there at the house visiting her and the children and she,
he heard Nell call their oldest son,
um,
by saying,
come here,
you little bastard.
And that moved him to formally acknowledged the boy as his son and set him up as
an Earl.
So now it was quite shrewd in the way that she handled the king.
She became one of his most popular mistresses because she certainly wasn't the
only one.
Charles had about 14 illegitimate children with a pretty much about the same
number of women and nearly became his kind of bit of rough at this time.
But he also had a posher mistress called Louise to carry while got the same time
and she was now probably to have been a French spy and Nell really loved winding
her up.
So she used to call her the weeping willow because she was quite an emotional
person.
But I think there's evidence that they liked hanging out together as well.
They played cards and eat macaroons together.
They did.
Yeah.
So it wasn't all handbags.
So now,
and Charles kept their romance alive until the King's death.
Uh,
and on his deathbed,
his famous last words were to ask his brother the soon to be King James the
second not to let Paul Nellie staff.
So James,
you know,
went along with this and he sat nearly up very comfortably and she lived very
happily until she died quite young of a stroke when she was just 38.
And she's buried in this of Martin in the fields church.
Um,
so she,
what made her such an excellent companion?
She,
it was her shamelessness.
Uh,
she didn't care about going along with respectable feminine ideals and she
wasn't ashamed of the kind of odd role that she had in society.
She seems to have been a loyal friend.
She certainly seems to have had a lot of fun.
She used to zoom around in a sedan chair eating oysters and macaroons.
She bought herself a silver bed with the king's face carved in it.
So she's certainly made the most of her position.
Um,
there was one time where she was caught in an angry crowd in her carriage and
the kind of mob around who are protesting because they thought that Louise,
who was very unpopular
was in,
was in the carriage.
And so she lent out the window and shouted,
I'm the Protestant Hall.
Because Louise would have been the Catholic one.
And the proud then dispersed in in quite a cheery way because they were
entertained by now.
She was very entertaining.
So the best lesson we learned from her was not to be so easily ashamed of
setbacks and to put ourselves out there despite the risk of embarrassment and to
make sure that we take time to enjoy the good things in life.
Like macaroons.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So next we move on to imposter syndrome,
which we think is the punishes undermine or of talented people everywhere.
So this is the idea that no matter how brilliant you are,
no matter how professional you are,
you believe the compliments are lies.
And you'll probably only one step away from being handed your p 45 and so how to
deal with it.
It's difficult,
but there's one historical homemaker,
Isabella beaten,
who'd maybe ought to have felt imposter syndrome but seems to have laughed in
the face of it and got on with achieving stuff.
So when I think of as Isabelle beaten before we came to research for this book,
I thought of this,
um,
matronly ladies talking the halls of some country house in her criminal ends
with the dish shouting at the servants.
But in fact,
and,
and actually sorry,
it is true that her book,
her is her famous book of household management does have some really deadly
tips.
There's one where she says,
when a mistress is an early riser,
it's almost certain they're house will be orderly and well managed.
On the contrary,
if she remained in bed till the late hour,
then the servants are likely to become sluggish.
And we particularly object to that one.
Yeah.
But actually she was this really young forward thinking entrepreneur.
She was a translator,
she was a journalist,
she was an editor.
And the brilliant thing about her is that she was really rubbish it cooking,
which was a surprise to me.
Um,
she was married to a publisher,
um,
who,
and she wrote articles for his magazine,
um,
and her first contributions were columns on cookery and pickling and preserving,
and they proved to be a massive hit despite the fact that she couldn't cook.
Yeah.
And she actually even missed out the flour and her first cake recipe and she had
to print an apology the next week because she had missed out the flower.
The other thing,
the other thing about her is that she actually stole most of her recipes.
So she'd been told by somebody that culinary expertise took decades to kind of
gather and she decided she didn't have time to time to waste doing that.
So it's just nick them basically and made very good use of the lacks copyright
laws at the time.
Um,
but what she did,
she did bring one really original thing to sort of recipe making,
which was,
she sort of invented recipes actually.
So she,
she was the person who invented writing them in a list.
So that you knew which ingredients he needs just to have to hand before you,
um,
before you got on with it.
You know,
she doesn't specify measuring them out into aspirational ceramics,
like on bake on.
What do you think she would have probably would have done?
Um,
so her husband ever,
the opportunistic publisher realized he had hot property and he cooked up the
idea of Mrs Beaton's book of household management.
It was a massive bestseller and actually it's still in print today,
nearly 150 years later.
It's what was the genius of it was,
it wasn't just the sort of 2000 recipes that it contains.
It also had tips on child rearing,
on
boundary property law,
on a menu planning.
Um,
so she was teaching this of the January had the generation of women around her
how to manage a household.
Um,
so after her death,
she died again.
This is the thing I hadn't really,
she died very young.
She was 28 when she died.
She died in after [inaudible] an infection after the birth of her fourth child.
And basically it was one of those moments where after her death,
her fame grew even more.
Um,
and you still find it on people's cookery shelves today.
But I,
what I love about her is she's this kind of dynamic woman who built this brand,
uh,
for domestic goddess newness,
but she was anything but really anything.
But so if you're suffering from imposter syndrome,
as I quite often do,
I look to Isabella and I think about,
um,
the way that she styled as she sort of understood that the path to success lies
in taking risks and not being afraid of your mistakes.
And in fact realizing that our floors are no barrier to being completely
amazing.
So this is our last woman and with Josephine Bake,
we've looked at the issue of having it all.
Now in the media,
having it all is usually used as a coded phrase to say that women can't or
shouldn't have what men have.
And as a female,
you're usually expected.
If you're having it all,
then that means you are ethically knee.
Combining an instagrammable home,
a loving,
passionate relationship with your partner,
uh,
stimulating and high powered career.
And also you look amazing.
And actually the life of celebrated dancer and singer,
uh,
Josephine Baker actually does tick all those boxes.
Uh,
she sets a very high bar,
but she certainly didn't achieve everything that she achieved,
um,
easily.
It wasn't given to her on a plate.
She was born in poverty in St Louis in 1906.
And as a child,
she had to Miss School in order to,
uh,
go out to work so that the family could pay the bills.
And she started dancing on the street and in clubs when she was a young
teenager.
And despite people telling her that she was too dark and too skinny,
she got really good.
She joined a dance troupe and natural charm and abilities,
led her to Broadway.
And it was from there that she got her really amazing big break,
which is that the company that she worked with when she was 19,
decided to go on tour in Paris in 1920s.
Paris was fascinated with the Harlem renaissance,
with American jazz and Primitivism.
And,
uh,
Josephine's dance number there,
which was called the dance.
Sovos required her to dance,
essentially only wearing a feather skirt and audiences loved it.
Obviously this fetishization of African culture feels wrong today,
but she grabbed that opportunity that she had,
um,
and she used to drive around in a,
in a Rolls Royce with her pet Cheetah Chiquita wearing lots of diamonds.
And then she went on to take on the act that made her really truly famous,
um,
which is a sort of spirited twerking number where she just wears a belt made of
sparkling bananas.
Um,
and from this point she became a complete sensation.
She was the most highly paid entertainer in Europe,
which is no mean feat for a black American woman.
She had hundreds of marriage proposal.
She was admired by Hemingway,
Picasso Free Carlo,
Collette.
And then she went on to train really hard to also become an accomplished singer.
And she became the first woman of color and kind of major motion pictures as
well.
Sadly,
when she returned on a tour to the u s her home country was not ready to accept
a beautiful,
rich,
talented black woman in this way.
And she met with quite racist reviews.
And so when she came back to France the next year in 1937,
she became a French citizen and her devotion to her new country was really
passionate.
When World War II started,
she worked with the resistance and she actually used to smuggle secrets around
in her sheet music and our underwear because she was able to travel as an
entertainer in a particular way that was helpful to the resistance.
And after the war she was presented with many honors for her service.
I love,
one of the things I loved when I was researching her is that if you find clips
of her speaking voices,
completely heavenly,
an extraordinary.
But there are also amazing photos of her receiving her medals from the French
government with her children and her children were another kind of key part of
her story.
So after distressing experiences trying to have a baby,
um,
she ended up adopting 12 different children from different countries,
different races and religions and the sides.
I wished to be a mother.
She also had a political purpose and this and that.
She wanted to build a rainbow tribe in order to prove that people from diverse
backgrounds could get along.
And she,
yeah,
she made her chateau into sort of theme park where people could come and see her
children and seeing the rainbow tribe together,
which,
which is,
uh,
you know,
a good intention.
But it must've been a very weird,
very strange,
but linked to this lends to this project of hers.
She also in the 50s became active in the civil rights movement in the u s she
refused to play to segregated audiences and Las Vegas.
And there was a famous incident in the Stork Club in Manhattan where they refuse
to serve her.
And she kicked up a huge fuss and this got her in a lot of trouble.
She was labeled as a commie troublemaker.
She was investigated by the FBI because of it.
Yeah.
And I suppose it's that thing that link to today,
it's sort of depressing that a woman kicking up first speaking her mind about a
perceived injustice is still something that even now we see as met with
disproportionate criticism,
but there was a happy outcome to the stork club incident,
which is that she formed a lasting friendship with Grace Kelly who happened to
be there and walked out at the same time.
And that's something we've found again and again through our book.
There's these incidences where women support other women and good stuff comes
out of that.
Yeah.
Because even later when Josephine actually,
the cost of running the kind of amazing chateau theme park,
uh,
sent her bankrupt and Princess Grace gave her a house in Monaco,
so that she could look after her.
Um,
and then it was only in 1973 that she,
Joe's been finally got the applause she wanted from the United States when she,
um,
did a performance at Carnegie Hall,
which was kind of rapturously received.
And not long after that she,
um,
she did another performance,
big grand performance in Paris,
uh,
to celebrate the first anniversary of her dancing there.
And it was only a few days later that she died and she was found dead in her bed
with her amazing reviews all scattered around her 20,000 people lined the
streets for her funeral and she was buried with full military honors.
So,
so she have older.
Yeah.
The question,
I mean,
when you look at her rags to riches tale and her professional excellence and the
lovely pictures of our cute kids in the castle,
uh,
it looks like it,
but she took a lot of fire from people who saw her as an upstart.
People who saw her four failed marriages,
thought she was a bizarre mother,
a political loose.
Callan cannon.
Obviously she went bankrupt.
Now she's recognized as the unique and powerful performer that she is.
And as a brave war hero,
civil rights activist and a style icon.
Yeah.
There are these great pictures of her and her huge sunglasses in late life.
She's wonderful.
And her influence in jurors.
She's inspired lots of people,
including Beyonce.
Um,
most of us would be immensely proud to have anything near the kind of life that
Josephine had.
Uh,
but she did work unbelievably hard to get it,
and she suffered a lot of setbacks.
I'm sure various points.
She didn't know that the end result would be this incredible career.
Uh,
so it was very liberating for us to realize that having it all means only going
for what you want on your own terms to the rest of your particular abilities and
expecting that things will always keep changing.
And that is certainly something that Josephine did.
So that's it.
That's our 10 are 10 women from the past who we believe can help our present in
really tangible,
concrete ways.
We have there a queen and inventor,
a spy,
a warrior,
a poet and explorer,
a priestess,
a concubine,
a cook,
and a dancer.
I'm all much more exciting jobs than most of us can have.
But all these women excelled at what they put their energies into.
And all of them left their mark.
And they certainly raised our sense of what's possible.
And they raised our spirits as well.
We had a really joyful time writing the book and working with the illustrator
bees,
you Carmen,
whose work you've seen behind us today and we hope that you and perhaps auntie
sisters,
daughters enjoy it and it gives you an amusing few hours and solves all of your
problems.
Thank you so much for having me.
[inaudible] so
we have time for some questions,
if anyone has any,
how did you go about your research and deciding who would be in the buck?
Yeah,
so the decision making was one of the hardest,
but also one of the most fun bits of it.
We actually have a list of about 290 other women and it's called spare ladies.
It's a document that we have.
One of the things to turns out,
women have been doing really great things for a really long time,
so we,
so we came up with it,
we came up with a list of modern dilemmas that we thought was,
we're worth answering.
And then we came up with a list of women and we were really clear that we wanted
the women to be representative of all different countries,
but also different disciplines.
So we're not,
you know,
we both work in a publishing industry.
So our natural instinct was to go with lots of writers and artists,
but in fact,
we wanted scientists in there and explorers and all those sports where men and
all those other fasteners.
And then just,
uh,
you know,
a quick look at a woman's life and you'd immediately see the little point there,
um,
answered the modern dilemma and that was the springboard for us to then go off
and research some more freely.
So there's definitely people who regret leaving.
Yeah.
Not In there.
There,
yeah.
Maya Angelou.
Yeah.
Feel bad about her.
You feel bad about Mary Queen of Scots.
You feel bad about Mary Queen of Scots,
but um,
but yeah,
maybe for volume two.
Yeah.
Um,
what inspired you on this subject?
Like now we know I was going to ask like,
what do you,
what do you do?
You work in publishing,
but what did you pick this subject?
So,
um,
genuinely came from watching the women's marches post the election in America.
Um,
we were really inspired by all those placards about nasty women,
um,
and the way that women were kind of a reclaiming it as a,
as a,
as from an insult into a positive term.
So we originally thought of it as a book celebrating the kind of nasty women of
the past and a lot of the women in our broker sort of difficult and complex.
And that was something else we wanted to,
to highlight.
They're not perfect any of these women,
they're sort of bad mothers or alcoholics.
Yeah.
Girlfriends.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And we really wanted to,
we wanted to show that,
that these aren't kind of bastions of,
of perfection,
but then we also,
as we said,
one to take it a step further and see is there a way that these amazing,
nasty women from the past can help us with modern dilemma.
So that was,
that was where it came from.
Do you have a favorite?
Oh yeah.
Uh,
Josephine's one of my favorites and I think,
um,
Isabella beaten.
There's one of my bios.
I do love Sappho as well.
Yeah.
No you can't.
It was a very joyful experience to write this book.
And Yeah,
they all,
Virginia West is really good too,
right?
Yeah,
she's great.
I'm free to say the [inaudible].
It's very difficult to get quoted on that.
Nice
that there's a children's book.
You went,
okay.
Good night stories for rebel girls,
which is doing a at a fairly similar thing.
What do you do you think is different about what you're going for?
So I think,
yeah,
I think the main thing is that ours is for a kind of older audience.
So we have swearing in our book and I love good night stories is a brilliant
book and my children read it and your children read it that night.
But that,
the premise of that is to present these women's stories as fairy tales.
And in a way what we wanted to do was quite different to that and that we are
depicting them warts and all and we are looking at adult problems in relation to
their lives.
So I mean that book is a gorgeous and wonderful book and we sort of hope this is
a kind of slightly older sister to it.
Yeah.
Yes.
That's a good way of thing.
Yeah.
But here we have some really difficult women and it's a Coco Chanel who I think
is also in,
I'm good night stories and what they don't talk about is her sort of Nazi
sympathizing past as well because obviously it's for children.
Yes,
do that.
But we do confront that in the book and kind of,
and then another figure who we really am denied over putting in now is Marie
stopes because she was,
she had,
she had some really dodgy kind of world views at the time.
But again,
that was really intentional.
We thought long and hard about that.
We wanted difficult women in there as well.
Yeah.
We didn't want to sugar coat it.
I'm just curious,
what is the most poignant lesson that you each have taken away from,
you know,
all the various chapter problems?
I,
I think for me
it really is this idea of women helping other women.
Cause that's something that we had.
And actually to be fair,
also,
there are lots of great dads and brothers and husbands in this book who are
really instrumental in allowing these women are helping these women achieve what
they achieved.
Yeah.
There's a lot of fathers who refuse to accept that their daughters couldn't have
a decent education.
Yeah.
So they would,
um,
educate them privately or find other ways to kind of instill,
education in them.
And that was that,
that was very moving,
wasn't,
it was,
yeah.
That they had to step outside of what was supposed to be allowed for girls and
the father supported them in that.
But we have,
so the princess grace and Josephine ones something that we love,
but also when we talk about the,
a tennis player,
Althea Gibson,
and she has an amazing kind of mentor relationship.
And so she was like health test,
the first black woman to win Wimbledon in the 50s.
And just there,
it's really moving that there are certain moments during her life where it just,
women sort of swooped in and really helped her.
So one,
uh,
one of the white champions at the time wrote this open letter to a magazine to
see it.
Come on guys,
why don't we let her into the lawn to lawn tennis association?
And that was a,
that was a great moment.
And then later in her life when she had sort of fallen foul of the American
healthcare system again and other women's swooped in and raised a load of moneys
pay for her health care.
So that,
that was really moving,
that,
that sense of women helping each other.
Um,
you say that you're very intentional in this tributing uh,
through different regions,
Tamsen history.
But you also say that you have a 290 style women,
if at any particular time in history or region that stands out for having a lot
of women in that period.
Hmm.
I mean,
I think what we tried not to do,
because ultimately what you do end up with when you look at these lists as quite
a lot of Victorian white women,
because that's where the records are there.
That's where the records documentation to be aware,
women suddenly did start to change the rich Victoria Victoria very well.
So that's why there are queens and all of these books.
Yes.
Cause there's loads of documentation about them.
So obviously it makes the research is richer.
And we were clear that we didn't want to do that to go to Saudi unusual places
in,
uh,
in the world and also in history and see what lessons in control there were
women we discovered for the first time and writing the book.
And that's something that we wanted to do was find out about people that we'd
never heard.
Uh,
yeah.
And so we have quite a few of them as well as having the big famous ones.
Yeah.